survivors of a religious cult on the
Kenyan Coast find themselves in
unfamiliar territory
they are reigned at a magistrates Court
in Mombasa County and put in police
custody for refusing to eat
they were rescued from the shakahola
ranch in malindi
that's where their preacher Paul
McKenzie encouraged worshipers to starve
to death so they could meet Jesus
the prosecutor wanted to charge them
with attempted suicide
the magistrate ruled 64 of the victims
should be taken back to a rescue center
where they will be supervised by the
court police and human rights lawyers
One Survivor opted to stay in a police
South without giving a reason her case
will be reviewed in two weeks each of
the 64 shalanda governmental assessment
and the individual reports to be filed
and the medical officer in charge coast
region compliance
human rights activists and lawyers who
are in court say the ruling was fair
an individualized assessment be done
in respect of each of the victims
and that such assessment
should be done by a qualified mental
health practitioner
McKenzie and other suspects appeared
before court on Wednesday they have also
been on a hunger strike
they looked weak and emaciated
some had to be helped as they walked
into the courtroom the death toll stands
at about
318 and Counting DNA testing still going
on
the police are still holding them as
they continue investigations
Catherine soy Al Jazeera Nairobi